That Time the Olympic Flag Went Missing for
77 Years and Turned Up in a Suitcase
The year was 1920.
The Summer Olympics were being held in Belgium
in the city of Antwerp.
At the end of the Olympic Games, the flag
suddenly went missing.
Fast-forward to 1997 and 101 year old bronze
medalist Hal Haig Prieste, who won his medal
in 1920 for platform diving, was being interviewed
at a U.S. Olympic Committee dinner.
During the interview, the reporter happened
to mention the missing flag to Prieste, who
then shocked everyone by stating, “I can
help you with that.
It’s in my suitcase.”
Prieste went on to reveal that he had been
dared by fellow diver Duke Kahanamoku to climb
the flag pole and steal the flag, which he
did.
He then folded it and put it in the bottom
of his suitcases, where it remained some 77
years until he decided to reveal he had it
at the dinner.
His reason for finally revealing he had it?
“I thought I ain’t going to be around
much longer – it’s no good in a suitcase…
I won’t be able to hang it up in my room.”
Prieste returned the flag to the IOC three
years later during the 2000 Olympics.
It was in reasonably good shape, thanks to
the fact that it had stayed protected all
those years in the bottom of his suitcase.
The only real damage to it was that the edge
was a little tattered from when he tore it
off the flag pole.
The Olympic Committee went about restoring
the flag and put it on display in the Olympic
Museum in Lausanne, Switzerland.
They also gave Prieste a plaque thanking him
for “donating” the flag that he had stolen
from them all those years ago.